America has dominated global finance
since the end of the Second World War
when the current system was built but
the economic disaster caused by the
corona virus pandemic could signal a new
chapter in financial history with
America's leadership called into
question could be 19 assume that America
is failing to sort out its own affairs
at home let alone provide global
leadership four hundred and eighty four
billion dollars for loans and after the
first round of funding ran out another
huge spike in unemployment claims with a
vacuum imagining at the top of the
financial order China is vying to
compete for greater control this is not
a case of China becoming Wall Street to
finance the crisis as probably China
with an opportunity to show what it's
capable of doing which in the long run
will tip the balance of power in global
finance America is king it controls the
world's financial plumbing and accounts
for almost a quarter of the world
economy the dollar makes up most central
bank reserves and is the currency of
international trade 80% of global supply
chains use dollars which gives America
significant power whoever controls the
flows of money at the end of the day
controls a lot of things in the economy
and ends up being the puppet master of a
lot of things that go on around the
world China hopes to correct this
imbalance there is a growing call from
the international community for
reforming the global economic governance
system which is a pressing task force
it's already has the world's second
largest economy its banks are enormous
the banking sector has been growing
fairly steadily for the past ten years
while in America Bank assets have
remained relatively stable and with
European banks assets falling Chinese
banks now have more assets than those in
Europe or America but most of their
business is within China Chinese banks
account for only 7% of cross-border
lending so the bank's vast size hasn't
translated into influence within the
world's financial system yet its banks
are becoming more active overseas
they are lending to companies in
particular Chinese companies that are
globalizing China is also giving its own
currency a more prominent role in
commodities market it has convinced a
few companies to use the currency Rio
Tinto which is one of the largest iron
ore miner in the world issued its first
contract in yuan last year the covert 19
pandemic could increase China's
financial influence China is now sharing
its experience with the rest of the
world and providing much-needed supplies
30 tons of equipment to Italy 500,000
surgical masks to Spain following the
outbreak in Wuhan China has positioned
itself as a global leader containing the
outbreak agreeing to deals to suspend
repayment of some of its loans and
charging ahead with vaccine development
the co bid crisis at least so far has
cast a negative shadow on the capacity
for leadership of America it did not try
even show interest in marshaling a
global response to this crisis it's
going to disappear one day it's like a
miracle it will disappear this could
offer an opportunity for China because
it's tried to fill the vacuum that
America has left in terms of global
leadership
China's tough response to the crisis and
the growing size and depth of its
financial markets have helped convince
investors it's a safe bet
even as ko bid sent other markets
crashing while emerging markets saw the
value of bonds plummet earlier this year
China's government bonds remained stable
which is a good gauge of trust in a
country's economy so China as the second
biggest bull market in the world covent
provided the first tests that this bond
market could resist the crisis in a way
that typically energy market bonds don't
it shows investors trust China as an
economy that they don't think it's going
to collapse overnight
[Music]
as well as improving its reputation with
international investors China hopes to
increase its hold over how money moves
around the world America has huge
influence over the current system thanks
to Swift the world's largest network for
transferring money it's a messaging
system that allows financial
institutions to communicate it's meant
to be too politically neutral but
because a majority of Swift transactions
are in dollars and these are routed
through new york america has used the
system to choke its adversary's russia
feared being excluded after its invasion
of Crimea and some Iranian banks were
blocked from using the system in 2018 to
enforce US sanctions so Swift is based
in Belgium so it is supposed to be
neutral however America has a strong
influence over its American can also
threaten Swift with sanctions if Swift
does not do what America wants this is
very upsetting for its allies which
would rather the system stays neutral
and for the benefit of everyone for now
China can't hope to challenge America's
dominance of Swift instead Chinese
companies are targeting a different part
of the financial system the way in which
consumers spend their money most
consumer payments rely on American
giants Visa and MasterCard but Chinese
tech companies have developed a series
of apps that disrupt this system rather
than using bank accounts or credit cards
for transactions consumers load money
into digital wallets consumers can then
do almost anything from paying parking
fines to making investments or ordering
taxis without any of this money flowing
through the banks creating a parallel
financial ecosystem this is potentially
very destructive to the financial system
it changes the way that when he moves
around the world it empowers a new set
of companies which are so big that even
his government is scared of them last
year Chinese customers made mobile
payments worth a total of 49 trillion
dollars and the two main Chinese
companies offering this tech $0.10 an
ant financial are enormous with a
billion users each covet 19 may increase
their reach people are doing more
shopping online trying to stay away from
cash which is seen as a potential
contaminant and this is all to the
benefit of electronic payment firms and
financial and $0.10 are already
expanding overseas and financials app
Ali pay is accepted in 56 countries in
regions and other digital wallet firms
are buying into their tech Ali pays QR
format has already been adopted by six
European mobile wallets America as
reasons to be worried about the Chinese
giants they are getting bigger in the
region because they are investing their
wallets in Southeast Asia and Beyond and
in effect it creates a system that is
not reliant on American companies
American standards American norms but
China faces a major obstacle much of the
world distrusts its intentions China
denying a cover-up top Chinese officials
kept it quiet after all Chinese leaders
initially denied and covered up the
spread of koban 19 there's always a
doubt about what is the ultimate
objective that China is pursuing in
being so collaborative at the prison
tone is not always transparent about the
truth and what happens in its own
country
in a global functional system you need
transparency you need to know the facts
what's going on to make sure the system
is in good health as China's financial
sphere of influence grows it's unclear
whether it will complement Americas by
creating more competition or undermine
the existing system in the end what we
could see is the fragmentation of the
global financial system in an America
dominated sphere and Oh China terminated
sphere these two systems don't have to
be mutually exclusive they could
actually collaborate with each other if
they do great if they don't then it will
be harder to move money around the world
it will be a costlier a more than just
functional system and in the end most
people will result China may not become
the dominant force in global finance
anytime soon but covert 19 is helping to
fast track its progress and as the world
recovers from the virus and economies
begin to open up China will be well
placed to make significant gains thanks
for watching I met you first famous
correspondent of The Economist and if
you want to read more about how the
current crisis is going to change the
financial system please click the link
opposite
[Applause]
you
[Music]